[Música]
i
he de confesar que cuando me invitaron a
participar y me preguntaron de que iba a
tratar esta plática yo no sabía
exactamente qué es lo que iba a venir a
compartir con todas y todos ustedes mil
temas pasaron por mi cabeza pasé una
noche completamente despierta pensando
en que les podía hablar me dice me
dijeron sabes que puedes hablar de lo
que haces en tu trabajo todos los días o
bien de aquello que te apasiona
demasiado
yo la verdad no sabía si hablarles de
que me dedico a trabajar temas de
perspectiva igualdad de género o de
atender a mujeres en situación de
violencia o bien hablarles de las
manualidades que me gusta hacer en mis
ratos libres no tenía la menor idea de
que les iba a hablar hasta que de
repente en esa noche hay altas horas de
la madrugada volteo a mí a mi lado y veo
un bultito que duerme conmigo un bultito
que recordé en ese momento que mucha
gente a lo largo de seis años me ha
dicho que cuando hablo de ese bulto los
ojos se me iluminan los ojos se me
iluminan cuando hablo de su llegada
cuando hablo de su espera cuando hablo
de sus locuras cuando hablo pues de
todas aquellas cosas que ella me regala
en la vida y pues bueno hoy les vengo a
hablar de ese bulto
ese bulto que el día de hoy tiene seis
años cumplidos y cachito ese bulto que
me llena de alegría todos los días y que
definitivamente vino a este mundo a
hacerme una mejor mujer
sin embargo
pues bueno su llegada no fue como todo
el mundo pudo haber esperado
ahí me encontraba yo
hace muchos años hablando de que yo
jamás iba a ser madre porque yo desde
muy pequeña empecé a estudiar estos
temas y me encontré con estadísticas
como esta en nuestro país 30 niñas entre
10 y 14 años dan a luz tienen bebés
niñas teniendo bebés 4 de cada 10
mujeres en nuestro país sufre violencia
sexual 400.000 embarazos son de menores
de edad cada año y estamos hablando que
estos embarazos entre 10 y 14 años no
son producto de un consentimiento
estamos hablando de la excesiva
violencia sexual que sufren nuestras
niñas méxico ocupa el primer lugar el
embarazo infantil en el mundo y nuestro
estado el tercero a nivel nacional
tercer lugar en embarazos en niñas entre
10 y 14 años y segundo lugar en
embarazos en niñas adolescentes de 14 a
19 años
ante esa perspectiva evidentemente yo me
encontré un domingo hace aproximadamente
6 años 10 meses saliendo de un baño con
una prueba de embarazo guau los métodos
anticonceptivos si fallan
esa niña es producto de ese 2% que una
píldora del día siguiente no funciona no
podemos irnos a la segura ahí me
encontraba yo con eso pruebe embarazo
frente a su papá diciendo qué carambas
pasó aquí si yo estaba segura si yo
estaba haciendo totalmente responsable
total que pasó un día completo y en ese
día yo entendí que era lo que quería yo
tomé una decisión y a mis 34 años decidí
ser mamá
de ahí transcurrieron 38 semanas exactas
en las que
pues obviamente te llegan los doctores
de vitaminas en las que afortunadamente
mi embarazo no sufrió ningún tipo de
náusea ni mareo ni nada entonces yo
obviamente me sentía la mujer más
hermosa del mundo jamás en toda mi vida
había amado tanto mi pan porque es raro
que alguien a mí su panza jamás había
amado tanto mi panza jamás me había
sentido tan plena sin embargo
evidentemente las dudas llegaron a mi
vida
llegaron a mi vida porque porque yo
tenía
a alguien a quien cuidar yo había
decidido hace mucho tiempo que yo no
estaba lista para cuidar un bebé sin ni
siquiera mi propia vida podían causar
muchísimo menos la de un bebé sin
embargo yo estaba ahí con una decisión
tomada entonces obviamente yo me hacía
miles de preguntas miles de preguntas de
cómo yo podía ser una buena madre porque
evidentemente esta construcción social
en la que vivimos nos pide que seamos
buenas madres
vienes de dudas pasaron a mi alrededor y
pues bueno pase de un embarazo
hermoso a un parto natural un parto que
disfrute incluso con aquello que el tema
de los famosos dolores de parto
pero sin embargo yo me preguntaba qué
puedo hacer para dejarle un buen legado
a mi hija
qué puedo hacer yo para pedirle a mi
pequeña criatura que fuera una mujer
feliz que fuera una mujer libre que
fuera una mujer plena miles de temas
pasaron por mi mente cómo podía yo
externarle a esa niña a esa pequeña
criatura que tuviera confianza en sí
misma cómo podría yo pedirle respeto si
veía a su mamá y escucha a su mamá
frente a un espejo quejándose porque
siempre hay algo que mejorar porque
siempre hay algo que mejorar quejándose
porque no es como ella quisiera ser como
puedo pedirle yo a una niña de seis años
hoy en día que se ame que se respete
cuando a lo mejor su mamá soporta
humillaciones cuando a lo mejor su mamá
soporto golpes cuando a lo mejor su mamá
soporta violencia
es difícil educar a una niña bajo este
entorno como puede educar a mi hija
pidiéndole respeto para las demás
personas si de repente escucha a su mamá
hablando de ahí va la gorda de finalista
y demás calificativos que le damos a las
personas a nuestro alrededor
pues bueno total que me di cuenta que yo
era esto yo era una feminista en
construcción por azares del destino la
vida me llevó a estos temas y hoy se han
vuelto mi bandera de vida una feminista
que estaba educando a su hija dentro del
feminismo pero no cualquier feminismo
dentro de mi feminismo porque este
feminismo que todos conocemos hoy en día
tiene muchas aristas pero cada quien lo
va construyendo de acuerdo a su propia
construcción personal
entonces pasó que un día me encuentro
con mi hija
en plena discusión un domingo en las
tantas horas de la noche ella y yo solas
ella en la peor tragedia de su vida yo
buscando ese botoncito de apagado porque
también una como madre se cansa y
diciéndole ya sabes que ya por favor
apaga te tantito pues yo lo único que se
me ocurrió fue de mirarle a los ojos y
decirle ya cállate
ya cállate
mi hija
con sus cinco años y medio más o menos
tomo fuerzas
respiro profundo tomó una gran bocanada
de aire me miró a los ojos con tono muy
tranquilo y me dijo mamá jamás me voy a
callar
para mí fue como todos esos temas que yo
estuviera estudiando todo este tema de
las gafas violetas de la perspectiva de
género en ese momento me atravesarán de
un jalón
escuchar decirle esa frase a mi hija tan
pequeña con su pequeña voz de su pequeña
boquita fue como estar escuchando a la
mejor oradora del mundo
es como estar escuchando esa psicóloga
que le dice una mujer que está en
situación de violencia no está sola o es
como estar escuchando a esa abogada que
en estos momentos está librando una
batalla en tribunales para defender un
feminicidio o una violación tumultuaria
escuchar esa seguridad por parte de ella
para mí me abrió un panorama de
expectativas muchísimo mayor de las que
ya tenía en mi vida
porque justamente es a donde yo quiero
llegar con esta plática hablarles de ese
empoderamiento de nuestras niñas y de
nuestros adolescentes
hablarles de lo importante que es
entender empoderamiento femenino no como
una lucha en contra de los hombres no
como algo que nosotros estemos
batallando y peleando porque porque si
hoy se nos antojó a pelear por eso
tenemos que romper con todos esos
estereotipos que como mujeres no se
encajonan estar en una cocina no se
encajonan a estar en el cuidado de las
familias sin que nos permitan
sencillamente hacer lo que queremos y de
eso se trata el empoderamiento de poder
tomar riendas de nuestras vidas de poder
decidir que queremos y que no queremos
hacer de tener control paulatino y poco
a poco acerca de nuestras expectativas
de nuestra ideología
tener estas pequeñas niñas puede darles
esas herramientas para que puedan tener
control de su físico
estoy hablando de su cuerpo que aprenden
que uno es uno y que todos los demás
como adultos podamos defenderlo estoy
hablando de su pensamiento que ya sean
libres de pensar y de creer lo que
quieran de dedicarse a lo que quieran
sin sentir ningún tipo de culpabilidad
que tengan derecho también aspectos
económicos intelectuales en un futuro
sean mujeres que puedan tener una
propiedad una carrera un legado que
darle al futuro
empoderar a una niña es muy difícil
sobre todo una niña tan chiquita porque
estamos en medio de dos mundos un mundo
en donde tiene que cumplir ciertas
reglas en una escuela en una sociedad
pero también en un mundo en el que
nosotros queremos que aprendan cosas
diferentes hoy en día mi hija entiende
perfectamente quién hacer compendio con
vagina no la hace ni más ni menos no
define ni su ropa ni sus juegos ni sus
gustos y sus deseos
hoy en día mi hija sabe perfectamente
que puede ser lo que ella quiera y
defender lo que viene un día puede ser
una princesa glamorosa llena de vestidos
y joyas pero que también no va a
depender de un hombre o que si ella
quiere ser alguna otra cosa diferente lo
puede llegar a ser hoy en día mi hija se
sabe poderosa sabe que su palabra vale
como esa jamás me voy a callar
hoy mi hija sabe que no importa si se
viste de mariachi ella quería ser un
mariachi no quería hacer otra cosa
empoderarla ha sido el mejor legado que
yo creo he podido dejar porque habla de
la congruencia que tengo como mujer la
congruencia que estoy llevando a cabo en
mis actividades diarias como
profesionista en mis actividades como
mujer en mi entorno general
me pedirían porque por favor dijera que
podemos hacer para empoderar a las niñas
la verdad es que no hay un manual que
ellos se les pueda dar aquí para
decirles vamos a empoderar a las niñas
vamos a hacer primero esto vamos a hacer
lo otro sin embargo les voy a platicar
de mi experiencia que he hecho yo con
elena mi hija se llama elena
he aprendido a escucharla he aprendido a
no criticar lo que ella me dice una
escucha afectiva he aprendido a que su
palabra vale y tiene muchísimo valor le
he enseñado a no sentir culpabilidad por
las por las tomas de decisiones que ella
tiene si el día de hoy decide no me voy
a bañar habrá consecuencias pero la
responsabilidad es totalmente suya le he
enseñado a que las demás personas valen
de la misma manera en que ella lo hace
también ella ha aprendido a no criticar
es muy importante no criticar las porque
si nosotros nos criticamos a nosotras
mismas que podemos esperar que ellas
salgan en su entorno para mi hija no
existe ni la gorda ni el gordo y
muchísimo menos la elena o la caro al
contrario hoy en día mi hija ya se
atreve a hablar con sus compañeros
acerca de momento no son cosas no le
diga ciudad o él
llámalos por su nombre
definitivamente el empoderamiento me ha
enseñado a que todas nosotras podemos
ser tomadores de decisiones que todas
nosotras podemos llegar a tener control
de nuestras vidas sin depender de nadie
y ojo dentro del feminismo empoderar a
las niñas ya las adolescentes no tienen
nada que ver con tener una rivalidad por
los hombres al contrario si nosotras
empoderamos a nuestras niñas a nuestras
adolescentes nosotras vamos a poder
generar temas que puedan ayudarnos a
reducir esas brechas de desigualdad que
existen entre hombres y mujeres
de ahí la invitación para el día de hoy
a través de estas pláticas es que seamos
justamente esas niñas esas
mujeres nosotras que seamos esas mujeres
que les enseñemos a esas niñas y esas
adolescentes
y haciendo juntas fuertes y unidas
podemos llegar a ser mujeres libres
mujeres fuertes mujeres poderosas porque
no importa si quienes estamos aquí vamos
o no vamos a hacer papás o madres si
tenemos o no tenemos hijos la
responsabilidad es de todas y es de
todos y poderosas podemos ser poderosas
empoderando a nuestras niñas y poderosas
siempre juntas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]